bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
petit rendez vous du mercredi
le lot qui deuil aujourd'hui et sorties
l'épisode 4 de la série law qui un
épisode très lourd en révélations et
conséquences concernant la suite des
événements bref la ya clairement matière
à débattre mais avant ça je vous
rappelle que vous êtes très nombreux à
regarder les vidéos sans être abonné à
la chaîne c'est le moment de le faire on
est très loin d'avoir terminé de parler
de l'eau qui il y à vraiment encore
beaucoup de choses à dire écoutez il
fallait que ça pète
à un moment c'est même tom hiddleston
qu'il avait teasé l'épisode 4 et 5 sont
les épisodes qui chamboule tout et qui
remettent beaucoup de choses en
perspective
rentrons dans le vif du sujet les thèmes
keepers n'existe pas réellement et en
même temps quelque chose sonner faux par
rapport à eux
ce que je veux dire par là ce n'est pas
forcément dans le sens du scénario mais
plutôt dans comment le mc hugh
fonctionne ils ont du mal avec les
entités suprême et c'est tout à fait
compréhensible c'est la porte qui
conduit vers un concept trop loin ou
trop tirée par les cheveux
nous avons l'exemple avec le tribunal
vivent une entité cosmique qui juge les
univers et les réalités et qui devait
apparaître dans infinity ward avant
d'être retirée et même de gros
personnage comme thanos ou même odin
sont simplifiées par rapport aux comics
du genre thanos qui est amoureux de la
mort elle-même et veulent impressionner
avec les pierres cela a été supprimée
pour le mc eu ou aux daims qui joue aux
échecs avec dormammu et qui font
égalités pour conserver l'équilibré de
l'univers
bref donc voilà je vais vous dire
j'étais même surpris de voir réellement
les time keepers c'était vraiment en
mode
ok ils n'ont pas fait que la chose sauf
que
si évidemment et c'était un petit peu
parlé pour luanda vision où nous
pensions voir réellement quiksilver et
en fait c'était juste un random gaye
bref tout ça pour dire que les concepts
sont simplifiées et remanié dans le mc
eu pour plaire à tous est resté
accessible
donc du coup qui a véritablement créé la
tva eh bien il existe deux cas de figure
pour moi déjà par rapport au times
keepers même si pour la blague
et là surprise il n'existe pas que ce
sont des machines et bien le concept de
time keepers existe bel et bien
ils sont les entités majeur de la tva
les mascottes
ils font partie de la propagande avec la
vidéo de miss minutes et sont présents
en tant que robots donc cela sous-entend
deux choses soit il existe véritablement
mais ont été emprisonnés et ou vaincus
et quelqu'un dirige la tva dans l'ombre
en se servant de leur image soit le
concept de timekeeper a été créée de
toutes pièces pour cacher l'identité de
celui ou celle qui dirige véritablement
la tva et cela sert en même temps de
référence trompeuses pour le spectateur
comme quiksilver
alors du coup il n'est pas impossible
que les timekeeper existe véritablement
mais ce qui va nous intéresser là ce
sont les secrets justement entourant la
tva
bien évidemment le fait que ramona soit
l'organisatrice ultime de tout ça n'est
pas assez sexy il y as forcément
quelqu'un derrière qui tire les ficelles
et
oui bon bah j'avoue j'ai envie de
reparler de gang je peux pas le nier
c'est même plus une possibilité c'est un
boulevard déjà on le rappelle ce sont
des choses que nous avions déjà traité
merav honnête un intérêt amoureux de
kong dans les comics et cette dernière
est comme l'a sous chef de la tva
l'entreprise est sa raison de vivre
elle c'est tout elle veut tout contrôler
elle cache de nombreux secret est ok je
suis d'accord sur le fait qu'on peut
aimer son travail mais cela va bien plus
loin que ça
ramona possède un intérêt à faire tout
ça et nous avons l'exemple avec le
flashback où elle a arrêté la jeune
sylvie elle n'était qu'une soldate parmi
tant d'autres aujourd'hui elle est à la
tête de la tva comme propulsé sans
oublier également son informateur secret
soit disant qu'il eut fait des petits
cadeaux et qui est même rappelé par
mobius dans cet épisode 4 son regard a
bien tarder sur le fameux stylo offert à
ramona simple détail mais qui peut avoir
son importance dans tous les cas cela
signifie que tout ce qui compose et
symbolise la tva c'est du bullshit
puisque dans le symbole
la figure emblématique des townshippers
traduisant la paix les sauveurs la
sécurité est basse et du feq
alors le message est on ne peut plus
clair sans parler des membres de la tva
symbolisant des gardiens de la paix et
qui sont au final de simples victimes
kidnappé de leur véritable vie et on en
revient à ce que je vous disais au début
le concept de tva est un concept
complexe et un petit peu tiré par les
cheveux qui va être compliqué à relier
véritablement omc eu la meilleure
manière de simplifier tout ça est d'en
faire quelque chose qui prétend être
mais qui au final ne l'est pas c'est ce
qui semble être le cas on retrouve un
peu la même thématique du rwanda vision
on nous présente le nexus 2 wendat un
endroit particulier ou vision est vivant
ou le temps passe différemment ou elle
peut avoir des enfants et au final tout
est fait qu une simplification de
l'histoire des comics qui serait
beaucoup trop complet
à mettre en place pour le mc sauf que la
différence ici est la question de savoir
qui a créé la tva une question posée par
l'eau qui lui même et si on garde l'idée
que la tva serait pourquoi pas contrôlé
par kang dans le secret cela concorde
également avec la mise en place de cette
technologie du temps propre à la tva
puisque dans l'épisode 1 sylvie qui a
tout volé à la tva était en possession
d'une technologie du troisième
millénaire l'époque de quang le
conquérant puis là où on parlait dans
les dernières vidéos que kang seraient
intéressés par une guerre multi vercel
c'est clairement le seul personnage de
marvel a souhaité ceci est bien là cela
sous-entendrait que kang a déjà instauré
son règne dans l'ombre permettant de
tizé par la suite la confrontation dans
antoine 3com wendat vision avec doctor
strange 2 et concernant l'eau qui est
mobius comme révélé dans la scène post
générique les bâtons des membres de la
tva ne semble pas tué mais qu'au
contraire ils envoient les victimes dans
une sorte de no man's land un endroit
hors du temps où tu es pagny et où tu ne
peux pas t'en sortir et au vu de
l'apparition de multiples variant de
loki dont la plupart viennent des comics
il semblerait que ce soit un no man's
land propres ou loki loki qui d'ailleurs
semble être une menace pour ramona
puisque si tout est bullshit et au vu du
flashback de sylvie il ya clairement un
problème avec les lots qui est si
justement nous devons creuser la
symbolique
cela veut dire qu'un jour un lot qui a
possiblement mis à mal le ou la
dirigeante de la tva ce qui a conduit à
une stigmatisation des lots qui bref
mais du coup cela veut dire que mobius
lui aussi n'est pas mort et qu'il est
certainement banny quelque part et la
jemmerais traiter une info un petit peu
particulière avec vous une sorte de
petit l'icm et j'attendais la fin de la
vidéo pour vous en parler car c'est
possiblement une sorte de petit spoil un
utilisateur à partager deux images
mon trentin mobius en train de traverser
le désert en egypte difficile de dire si
c'est le vrai mobius au vu de sa tête et
notamment à cause de la moustache qui
est absente
mais ce qui m'intrigue le plus est le
fait qu'il soit en egypte car comme je
vous le disais dans la vidéo dédiée à
quang il existe dans les comics un
quatrième timekeeper banny est bloqué
dans l'egypte antique et si justement
pour la réadaptation du mc eu si les
thèmes qui peur existe vraiment ils
seraient bannis en egypte en référence
aux comics comme pour le 4ème timekeeper
il pourrait donc nous dévoiler la vérité
sur ce qu'il s'est passé et terminer la
série sur de grosses révélations qui
vont teasé la suite des événements
hashtag kong hashtag ant man 3 bref je
pense que c'est suffisant pour
aujourd'hui
l'épisode était vraiment ouf et je peux
vous assurer que j'adore avoir ce petit
rendez vous avec vous tous les mercredis
il se peut au final que les nexus les
réalités les variants etc
ce ne soit pas si néfaste que ça et que
justement la tva est le seul frein pour
spider man de rencontrer les autres
spiderman mais bref nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler
je vous invite en tout cas vraiment
avoir les autres vidéos que j'ai fait
sur l'eau qui car cela traduit
complètement mon schéma de pensée à
travers la série j'ai pas envie de vous
ennuyer et de répéter les mêmes choses à
chaque vidéo il y a des éléments dans
les épisodes précédents qui reste
toujours très mystérieux et dont nous
avons déjà traité dans tous les cas
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo j'espère
de tout coeur qu'elle vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleu un petit commentaire sur ce que
vous avez pensé de l'épisode
et puis à vous abonner bien évidemment
allé cet argot rock et que le 'lion'
rares sont avec vous ciao tôt
[Musique]